hey guys merry here at PAX Prime 2015
and we're working with the mix to bring
a bunch of awesome indie games into your
attention and I'm here with Tucker from
adult swim games how's it going good
that'll be here yeah I'm excited to see
this this is a game that I saw it I
definitely wanted to check it out it's
like a super fast paced frenetic
supersaturated shooter it's called d
sync yeah so d sink like you said it's a
fast paced FPS and it's built around a
combo system so a little bit like double
may cry series or even Bulletstorm where
you are discovering combos yeah and
really the goal of the game was to
create an FPS experience where players
couldn't get comfortable with their
patterns so if it wants you to never be
doing the same thing over and over you
know relying on the same system and it
does that by creating like a whole
series of enemies he's telling me I can
get this bug off my screen there by
shaking him before you damages me um
basically all of the weapons which I'll
pick up some different types besides his
pistol here in a minute but they all
interact with each other to create what
are called attack sequences and attack
sequences are basically more powerful
ways of engaging your enemies than just
shooting them one time so blast me an
enemy into the air and shooting him
while he's airborne would be an example
I'm gonna try and pull and real quick
break here nothing so there I just
unlocked the first one here condesa
which is destroying an enemy with an
exploding piece of the level there right
right so you're actually using the level
to your advantage to take them out can
they do that to you as well uh yeah they
can totally blow itself up he hurts you
and surprised you pretty bad but there's
literally hundreds of these sequences
that you can use against your enemies
and different enemies are gonna be you
know more effectively dispatched with
different ones right tell me a little
bit about the HUD here there's a lot of
stuff on it all you got something else
going on you know I just don't like to
know
one by a pistol shooting an enemy out of
the air okay guy there so yeah there is
a lot actually going on here you see
that affability there i'm going to use
that is an equippable ability that
allows me to get some health back okay
um and your health is determined by the
heart square see that 87 down there yeah
in the corner yeah that's your health
yeah that's good health so tell me about
the heart then so the heart is like an
equippable item okay you're using again
to redo to replenish your health exactly
to know it's gonna take a while to
recharge and there's a bunch of
different kinds that you'll unlock as
you play the game and you can sort of
tailor your play style as you unlock
more of these so there I just got
another one all these attacks sequences
go into kind of like a dictionary which
you can look up because as the game gets
more complex certain enemies have to be
defeated with these attacks sequences
rather than just trying to shoot them
okay in a minute here we're gonna see
you just got a new weapon yep this is
like a grenade launcher is actually one
of my favorites yeah um it has two modes
one of which makes the grenades sticky
and will attach to enemies and that's
what i just did I stuck a grenade to him
and then shot a regular grenade Adam
okay and i unlock the detonator sequence
right there now this guy is what the
name of the game comes from he has that
blue aura on him yes because he's synced
which means that he's more powerful than
regular enemies and in order to more
effectively defeat him you can use
particular attack sequences to take that
buff off okay sink him exactly so as you
encounter different scenarios you're
going to run into like a bunch of
situations where you have to use new
methods every time and the game actually
records every attack you make every move
you make and analyzes them and it
determines the scoring so the more
creative you are the more variety of
attacks you use then the higher your
scores are whereas using the same move
over and
over again yields Leslie the game is
rewarding you for experimenting yeah and
that was really the goal to make sure
you're never comfortable you're always
trying new things and that even ties
into the leaderboard system the game has
a very robust leaderboard system that
will notify you anytime a friend you
know beats your scores and you can take
advantage of their playing behavior to
try and like count score them when you
repeat a level okay it looks like um you
know you're meant to die a lot in this
game but it's letting you reconnect
immediately it wants you to get back
into the from and like into the fray and
just keep fighting it out and that's
also kind of noticed with the music here
you got like some serious fast-paced
music going on to keep everyone's
attention and go go go exactly its high
speed high intensity but never to
punishing to let you always be trying
new things and we're when do you expect
to see decent coming out 2016 as
unfortunately as specific as I can get
okay what platform we're into it pc this
is a pc gamers game it's designed mouse
and keyboard like from the start and
they're really passionate about that pc
FPS experience sweet well thanks sucker
for showing me that game yeah thank you
awesome so that was decent guys and for
the latest on all games be sure to head
to gamespot com